what is the EU just an economic block
what if the EU guaranteed minimum wages
pensions a life of dignity we the
Socialist and Democrats are aiming to
build a truly social
Union the resolution is
adopted I'm talking about that here
today in Brussels with Agnes yarus a
trade unionist from the Netherlands and
an MEP in our political group Agnes what
is the social Union it's about Protec
people from the challenges of our uh
time it's about
protection uh it's the reason why we Pro
proclaimed the European pillar of social
rights because we said people should
have a life in dignity uh with Fair
wages with access to all kind of Public
Services with access to Social Security
and with equal treatment and the
European pillar of social rights
Translate
an uh directive on adequate minimum
wages MH uh a directive on equal pay for
men and women uh and a protection of
workers for uh working with dangerous
substances because we don't want people
to become ill from their uh work if a
deliverable biker at the moment get an
accident uh while delivery uh the meal
to the client he's not protected or
she's not protected uhhuh and at this
moment we trying to close that loophole
in our social system by saying every
worker deserves basic social protection
that's on our plate at the moment and
and why is this like an EU issue why is
this not something we're doing we should
focus on nationally there is of course
for a long time a concentration of the
European projects on only
economic uh uh activities uh uh the
internal
the internal Market but if you have an
internal Market uh while you're not
protecting the workers then it's clear
that in a labor market or in any Market
with a fierce competition employers
companies are looking for how can I
reduce my cost by paying my workers as
less as possible and contribute as less
as possible to the welfare systems uh
and uh taxation so if you really want to
function the internal Market properly
and working for everyone yeah we also
need to have this basic social rules
because otherwise it will be competition
at the cost uh of the Fate uh of just
ordinary workers a race to the bottom a
race to the bottom uh because internal
Market rules are being considered of
more importance uh than the social uh uh
rules we think social rules uh should be
at the same level economy is for the
workers it's it's not for the profit of
the shareholders they had enough in the
uh uh uh last uh uh years it's now time
yeah to get even and give workers their
fair share just talking about giving
workers their fair share do do you think
we're going to get towards that it is an
uphold Circle but we can win this and I
think we can win this while keep
explaining that an internal Market which
doesn't deliver for ordinary
people uh will lose the support uh of
citizens in Europe uh if only companies
if only shareholders are profiting from
this internal market and the workers not
then people are saying I'm turning my
back to this European projects yeah uh
while if we work together in a good way
uh also on social issues yeah we can
fight this race to the bottom we can
fight
exploitation uh and I think it's clear
uh given for instance that truck drivers
from Kazakhstan Belarus far from the
European uh Market working on the
European uh labor market for Polish
companies driving in the Netherlands and
Germany yeah they were exploited because
the companies made use of the loopholes
in the system right and they had to be
on strike for uh more than six six weeks
on a parking place in Germany near FR
frankurt we don't want this we don't
want a labor market in internal markets
at the cost uh of the expectations and
dreams of ordinary people so if you want
to stop the race to the bottom we have
to combine forces also on the social uh
issues and yes it's not always easy and
yes there are also companies will say ah
social rules big an administrative
burden we don't want this you want quick
and dirty competition but quick and
dirty competition at the expense of
workers yeah that's not fair it's not
just us working on this in the
parliament uh National governments also
involved and especially our our national
governments we spoke to Spain's Deputy
Prime Minister Teresa rera and we asked
her do we currently have a social Union
doing progress I think that it is good
what we have achieved in this Mandate of
the commission but I think that we need
much more I think that we have
understood to what extent it is
important that citizens feel that they
are Europeans because Europe is an idea
of progress solidarity and Equity it is
impossible to think on firmness and
Equity without taking into consideration
environment and values linked to
ecosystems and there is this dimension
of uh the social Union of Europe
connected to the green Union of Europe
that are part of what we are trying to
push forward in the in the Spanish
presidency
of the European Union I think that we
need to to think and to craft carefully
how create opportunities and this been
social services that do work social
policies that do work capacity to ensure
access to the benefits of um water
resilience to climate uh dealing with uh
energy and dealing with skills and
Innovation and employment and this means
that we need to combine the traditional
social policies with the economic
policies and the green policies do you
think we have a social Union at the
moment and do you think we have a
genuine uh strong will uh to be do you
think we could be proud of the social
Europe we've built so far I think we can
be proud uh and we need to be proud
because if it hasn't been for us yeah
the social pillar uh wouldn't have come
uh into uh practice uh and if it hasn't
been uh for us uh and also our
governmental leaders like Costa Len uh
will keep pushing for this we would not
have come so far uh in this previous uh
period but on the other
hand we are not there yet uh uh so we
made rules around equal pay men and
women protection of workers against
dangerous substances we have made rules
and regulations around minimum wages but
there is much more more to be done yeah
uh the social pillar by itself uh is
also containing a variety uh of uh of
issues also for instance affordable
housing access to Social Security good
Public Services education for all young
people and we are not there yet so with
the social pillar with the achievements
we made so far it's not time to just sit
and lay back but it's time to sit and
continue the uh continue the fight um uh
I think we have uh uh the reality uh on
our side that if the internal Market is
not completed with a social uh Union
yeah things will get out of a track yeah
uh but we need to keep pushing yes
indeed um austerity kills and we're
convinced that we can't go back to that
um I asked Esther Lynch uh the leader of
euk if austerity is over the real danger
we have at the moment is that austerity
is going to come back uh we already see
governments with trial runs whether it's
pension ages whether it's taking
payments away from uh families with
children whether it's the calls to make
sure that unions can't bargain can't go
on strike so very far from being over
all the signs are that there's a real
threat that austerity is going to make a
comeback that's why it's so important
the discussions that are going to happen
in the European Parliament between now
and the end of the year what we need to
make sure is that the economic rules do
not require member states not to invest
in uh the we say industrial policy or we
need to make sure that member states can
invest so that they can invest uh for a
just transition so they can invest in
schools so they can invest in hospitals
everything that's needed to make Europe
genuinely competitive what we need is
invest for that so we have the
possibility for a social Europe working
together we saw that we managed to have
legislation to uh increase minimum wages
a threshold of decency to make sure that
uh there's 80% of the workers in Europe
are going to be covered by a Collective
Agreement means that pay will be fairer
conditions will be more decent so
there's lots of possibilities for there
to be a social Europe but it really
comes down to who uh the electorate will
vote for next year because next year
what we need is a parliament of
politicians fully committed to
delivering a fair Europe a fair Europe
for working people their families and
communities are you on guard for a
return to austerity and and is there
anything we can do to prevent it I share
the fears of Esther Lin uh because uh
like I said before there are people who
think H enough uh uh social uh now it's
time for uh business as usual and have
harsh rules uh for all the uh member
states and if we don't give room for
social investment and for social
protection of uh
workers a emphasis only uh uh on the uh
budgetary rules uh uh will lead to a new
mhm emphasis uh on aity and we can't
have that yeah the main thing we can do
uh about it is of course winning the
elections so uh in the uh new European
elections yeah we have to fight for a
strong position of the social Democrats
uh because we are fighting for this
agenda uh and we need to be strong in
the parliament to make this fight also a
success thanks so much for your time
we're going to conclude with the words
of John D podesta senior adviser for
clean energy Innovation and
implementation in Biden's White House um
he spoke recently an snd event that we
had on building the social Union in
Brussels so we'll finish with John
podesta's words thanks so much for
joining us Agnes thank you we're feeling
the urgency of the climate crisis like
never before in the US we've had
devastating fires in Hawaii catastrophic
flooding in the Northeast extreme heat
and drought in the southwest and
hurricane adelia in the Southeast just
in the past month and of course this
summer uh people across Europe have
experienced scoring heat waves uh
devastating fires and the places my
grandparents came from flooding and
landslides the climate crisis is truly
an existential threat it's already here
that means we have to seize the moment
of peril and turn it into opportunity
that's what we're trying to do with the
IRA it's time to jump in with both feet
for the US that meant passing historic
climate Investments through the
inflation reduction act the law is
already accelerating our transition to
clean energy putting us on a path to
reach our national Target of cutting
emissions by 50 to
52% below 2005 Levels by 2030 just by
way of comparison that's essentially on
an Apples to Apples basis uh equivalent
of a 55% reduction that uh Europe is uh
trying to achieve our mission was
inspired by Europe's leadership on
climate uh through laws like the green
deal we hope to inspire even more action
both here in the United States in Europe
and around the world make it easier for
other nations to achieve their
goals resolution is
adopted